in Iran rights groups say Security
forces have killed a dozen people in the
last 24 hours in a Crackdown on
demonstrators in Kurdish populated
regions activists say five people were
killed when police opened fire on
protesters in the western town of
javanrid now Kurdish regions have been a
focus of anti-government protests since
the death of Kurdish Iranian woman Masa
amini in the custody of the morality
police last September despite the
intensifying Crackdown though the
protests show no sign of abating
and you study by the Tony Blair
Institute for Global change shows strong
and consistent support for regime change
in Iran and to hear more about its
findings I spoke to Kasra Arabi earlier
who's the Iran program lead at The
Institute
sure so the new study the polls in our
new study was conducted uh by the group
for analyzing and measuring attitudes in
Iran Gammon they use encrypted services
in their polling methodology that
enables Iranians inside Iran to answer
freely without fear of consequence for
their lives now the polls were conducted
in
um 2020 and again in early 2022 and they
as you said overwhelmingly show support
for regime change and this really
underscores that what we're seeing on
these streets of Iran is not a flash in
the pan moment it's not a random uh
occurrence it's been clear for years
that the Iranian people uh want regime
change but unfortunately the West was
completely blindsided to this by
exclusively focusing on the 2015 nuclear
agreement if I could just ask you I
believe the findings of the poll suggest
that fully 70 percent of Iranian men say
they are opposed to mandatory hijabs
were you surprised by that
uh quite quite in fact the honest answer
is no I'm not surprised by that for
those of us who have been studying uh
Iran for for years uh and have been to
Iran and uh have uh been frequently
engaging with the people of Iran this
isn't surprising uh despite living under
a Theocratic Hardline islamist regime
the Iranian people are the most secular
in the Middle East uh and the the
numbers the numbers should suggest that
um look only 26 of urban Iranians say
they pray five times a day similarly
only 33 of Iranians say they of rural
Iranians say they follow the Islamic
prescription Iran's society has
undergone unprecedented secularization
and since 2017 it's been clear that the
Iranian people want regime change and
look 70 of men are opposed to the
compulsory hijab 74 of women are opposed
to the compulsory hijab and this is the
significant point
84 of those who are against the
compulsory hijab also want regime change
that's what we're seeing on the streets
of Iran today people are demanding the
downfall of the Islamic Republic in its
entirety this isn't about reform this is
about
the downfall of harmonize regime so
would you say that Iranian societies
essentially reached a Tipping Point
yes and it's been clear as I said for
years now at least since 2017 that the
Iranian people want to get rid of this
regime uh let's not forget the bloodiest
Crackdown on on civilians took place
under the presidency of so-called
reformist uh Hassan Rouhani and his for
and his foreign minister Javad zarif uh
they facilitated the biggest Bloodshed
on the Iranian streets in November 2019.
the idea that the Islamic Republic can
be reformed was false it's a lie the
past 30 years have shown that and the
Iranian people have had enough they are
calling for the downfall of the Islamic
Republic in its entirety reform will not
suffice tasra Arabi from the Tony Blair
Institute for Global change thanks so
much for your time
thank you
[Music]
and Iran's men's football team dominated
headlines on day two of the Qatar World
Cup not with a score but with a poignant
Act of protest against their government
it came before they kicked off their
first group match against England
a silence that spoke louder than words
as Iran refused to sing their national
anthem ahead of kickoff in the match
they held firm for 35 minutes but then
19 year old Jude Bellingham headed in
for his first England goal and the
floodgates opened bakay Osaka doubled
the lead next with a superb strike two
minutes before the break
and in injury time Raheem Sterling added
another to make it three nil at half
time
Saka grabbed a fourth for England in the
second half but Iran got off the mark
shortly after in the 65th minute
but hopes of a comeback were dashed as
Marcus rashford added a fifth and jacked
relish a sixth a late Iran goal from the
penalty spot did little to dampen
England's mood or improve that of the
Iranian team